it's been hard to ignore the latest
obsession in the United States Russia
over the last few years Russia has taken
steps that haven't exactly made the u.s.
too happy from militarily intervening in
Ukraine and Syria to allegedly tampering
with the u.s. presidential elections
Russia has kept the u.s. on its toes
since 2014
in fact in February 2016 Secretary of
Defense Ashton Carter revealed that the
number one threat facing the United
States was in fact Russia so it's a time
to get worried well let's look at why
Russia has done what it's done in recent
years so let's start with Ukraine a
matter of national security one of
Russia's biggest goals has been to
counter NATO's presence in its own
backyard and there's good reason in the
past two years there's been NATO troop
buildup in Estonia Lithuania Latvia
Norway and Poland Vienna yes I noticed
it's a pretty new training process my
only organ is earthy younger than usual
most inertia so when you cranks possible
membership in NATO came up Putin decided
to draw a red line
a real one then there's a Russian
military intervention in Syria which has
claimed over 2,000 civilian casualties
and significantly helped the Syrian
government serious corner of TOCOM
saskia new extraña career
Padilla status engaged a group you
sustained virologic seriousness to patil
inerrancy increased russian air support
led to the eventual fall out rebel
controlled East Aleppo the biggest
battleground in the war now Russia has
positioned itself as a major piece
broker for Syria sidelining the United
States which was noticeably absent in
the 2016 Moscow negotiations and if
Russia does manage to eventually
facilitate a peace deal for Syria not
only will it strengthen its influence in
the region
but that will make it a major power
broker and that's not exactly an
exciting prospect for the United States
finally there's the alleged Russian
involvement in the 2016 US presidential
elections and president Donald Trump's
own rapport with Vladimir Putin early on
in the primaries then candidate Trump
raised eyebrows by praising the Russian
leader if he says great things about me
I'm gonna say great things about him
I've already said he
is really very much of a leader but the
real kicker was in late December 2016
when the US government formally accused
Russia of hacking the DNC and obtaining
and leaking emails shortly after
President Barack Obama issued an
executive order for political sanctions
against Russia and expelled 35 Russian
diplomats the second set of sanctions in
the span of a week this despite the FBI
DHS Intel report released on December 29
2016 being characterized as a week by
some critics regardless of what role
Russia itself played or didn't play in
the u.s. elections having a friend in
the highest office of your biggest foe
what's probably on Russia's list of
things we need in 2017 considering the
other candidate compared to Putin to
Hitler and proposed a no-fly zone in
Syria which would have put the United
States in direct military confrontation
with Russia so time to be worried about
Russia right well maybe not in 2016
Russia has scaled back on Ukraine and
began withdrawing ground troops from
Syria it also chose to not respond to
the United States political sanctions
continue to deny any involvement in the
elections meaning Russia might not be
looking for a fight but with fears of
Russia still running high will tensions
escalate
[Music]
you